- They're moving all my fucking dates,
I can't make any money.
I'm fucking sick of these fucking people.
God help me.
(crying)
- [Mark] Darlin' are you okay?
- No, I'm not okay, I
can't make any money.
This fucking person keeps bugging me.
- [Mark] Let me give you something,
just to help you out today, all right?
- Huh?
- [Mark] Let me give you some money
just to help you out a
little bit, all right?
You want to come by my
place just to hang out?
- Sure, sure.
- [Mark] Here, hop in.
- They still keep blocking me.
They still keep blocking me, man.
Unblock me, c'mon, help me.
9-11, 9-11.
Get this bitch fucking dead man.
Get him dead.
Die, bitch.
- [Mark] Where are you staying now?
- Oh, just nowhere.
- [Mark] What did you smoke last night?
- Oh it's nothing about that.
- [Mark] No?
- No, no.
No, it's fucking them trying
to take the riches of God.
Could I just borrow $2 and get out?
I'm just too upset.
- [Mark] Okay, sure.
- I'll try to give it back to you.
If I made money, I always pay people back.
These people won't even let me
fucking make any money
to pay anybody back.
- [Mark] Here's some money.
- [Caroline] Thank you.
- [Mark] Come see me later,
I'll take care of you.
- [Caroline] Okay, thank you.
- [Mark] All right, you know that.
- [Caroline] Thank you.
- [Mark] Okay so Caroline,
Caroline, I talked to you first,
when was the first time we talked?
- For eight years, eight years ago.
- [Mark] Probably about eight years ago.
- 'Cause the time went by pretty fast.
Yeah, about eight or nine years.
- [Mark] So how have things changed
in your life since then?
- Oh, man.
I guess I just been taken
apart really, my body.
- [Mark] You still smoking heroin?
- Yeah, I smoke black and crack.
- [Mark] You do crack too?
- I do crack, yeah, but -
- [Mark] Is that something
you did back then?
- Well see, yeah, I always
smoked crack, yeah, yeah.
But you know, the heroin is the tannin
and the heroin, the tannin
was in the environment.
And these people saw this
whole, this group of people
of people that they left, I
guess, rise above with God.
And they knew it was from tannin
that they got really powerful and strong.
They took tannin out of the environment
so these people couldn't
prevail and they made it into,
and that's what heroin is, it's tannin.
It's a holder of tannin.
- [Mark] Okay.
- And just a whole...
- [Mark] So where are
you sleeping nowadays?
- And then crack is a
coconut, everybody needs it.
It's more than what
you think, the coconut.
- [Mark] Really?
- Yeah and it also makes people
a little bit clairvoyant,
a little bit, they can see cameras.
They can see some, yeah, they're...
- [Mark] Hmm, very surprising.
- I don't.
- [Mark] But where do you stay at?
Where do you sleep?
- Different spots, I
go to my friend's place
in the city of Burnet,
I go to Mario's house.
Mario's, it's like a junkyard.
I sleep in a U-haul truck with him.
It looks like it's decorated.
It's painted inside and there's varnish
and enamel flowers painted,
but it's really a U-Haul.
- [Mark] So you mostly
stay here in the street?
- I do stay on the
street, I go there, I go,
but yeah, my friends have
a tent on St. Julian,
they've been letting me
sleep in it by myself
which has been really nice.
But there's all kinds of trajectory,
like if you could see, like,
the amount of trajectory
being pulled on my teeth, my upper molars,
I won't have any teeth
in about, very fast,
if somebody doesn't do
something about it really fast.
- [Mark] And who's controlling that?
- Well I don't know, but
I know there's a woman
to the right of me, you know,
if I'm sitting in my tent.
This woman to the right of me
and then there's some
people to the left of me,
this guy, Dennis, I think
she's the possessor of him
or some greater force, but...
But they're doing something with it
'cause I know she's the trajectory,
that's her employment with
this regime on the streets here
is dealing with the
trajectory and the returns.
How the trajectory intertwines
with the returns when they...
Like today, we saw some of it, you know,
like for instance whatever
was taken, removed
from Mark's body that's bad,
if it returned, it got
returned because of this
fucking trajectory being put in my teeth
and other people, maybe even himself.
You know, so everything that,
in this linguistics thing,
they stole certain sounds from my mouth.
And so when I've been saying,
let me see this, these
templates and things
they made with these
linguistics that were stolen,
it all of a sudden, it lightens 'em up
and it shows, it does show
when you lie and steal.
It does show up, you know?
It comes out and it's
starting to come out.
- [Mark] And uh, for the heroin
and the crack that you...
- I'm a prostitute, yeah.
Prostituting yeah, I hate it.
- [Mark] So what hours are you out there
making money?
- I'm out there usually, I surface about,
sometimes 5, 6 o'clock in the morning.
If not the latest I'll get back there
about 8 o'clock unless I sleep all day,
we're talking to like 2 or 3.
So you gotta, yeah.
- [Mark] And do you go to the night or...?
- I just keep doing it as I go along,
I buy my stuff and I take a break
and then I go back, I
just chase it all day.
I haven't gotten to that point
where I'm trying to fix that,
'cause I'm trying to
do so many other things
and I feel like I'm here, my
mom just moved to Seattle.
She just moved in with my sister
so I can't really go back home now.
And so you know,
I'm gonna try and get some housing
because I want my daughter
to come stay with me.
- [Mark] Do you ever see your daughter?
- I saw her last week, yeah.
- [Mark] She came down here?
- No I went down to Orange
County to see my mom.
I just happened to call there,
I was in my friend's car
and they were just filling
up the moving truck.
They were leaving the next day,
my sister was here from
Seattle, I got to see her
after like 15 years, or you,
10, 15, years, yeah, yeah.
- [Mark] How'd it go?
- That was really nice, I had a good time.
Although I was in the car
a couple times getting high
but I just, I couldn't
handle the whole pressure
just being down there and
just the whole moving thing
and not knowing where my
daughter was gonna be.
Really hard.
- [Mark] How old is she now?
- 21.
Yeah, she's 21 and she,
she might go to school but, I dunno,
she drove there with 'em.
She wasn't gonna drive there,
I called the next week
and she was with 'em.
She was with her dad that
lives in Vancouver, Washington,
which is not far from Seattle, I guess.
So she drove out there with 'em
so she'll come back on the airplane.
And I don't know where she's going.
- [Mark] And your issue with her is,
she's warm with you?
- She's okay with me, yeah.
- [Mark] Understanding of
what your situation is?
- Yeah, totally.
- [Mark] And your mom?
- Yeah.
I think she loves me no matter what.
- [Mark] What kinda
things do you say to her?
- I hug her a lot.
- [Mark] It's some heavy
stuff to talk about.
- Well because I hear
screaming all the time
when I'm on the street here.
'Cause she's the savior, the big savior,
there's something big about her
that these people are, got everybody like
almost like evil robots.
They say it's from my breasts,
like if I could pull 'em back right now,
they have any of them out, you know?
And these little people all over my body
that are in there just sending
all my colored energy out,
they're doing a lot of bad stuff.
I met this guy yesterday
that I did a date with
him, I saw him on Mercer,
he'd been in my body since, for 48 years,
he's lived in my body.
Yeah, he's only been out
of my body two times.
Yesterday was one of them, I met him
and he said they ran.
I can't believe the
scams they pulled on him.
I just showed him maybe three things
of my God sense and he was like tripping.
So even being inside the body of me,
you can get fooled really bad
'cause there's some scandalous people
that really need to get out of there.
And so that's what I'm trying to say.
If somebody could see this on YouTube,
you need to go and you need to see
who's connected to my nose
and how much power they have of my nose,
the swallow, the breasts,
and all the switching,
exchanging, trading and
if you don't understand it
just start with that, you'll get there.
But as well as my feet have been taken,
I think this guy took the
top part of my vagina,
like the mound.
And one day I got out
of this guy's Suburban
near McDonald's I couldn't do anything
but just masturbate on
Olympic and Central Avenue
on the corner.
I was laying there masturbating
in front of the cars
'cause something went wrong with my body,
somebody took something
really, really super important.
And my body just went into,
and I know why it didn't
fix, it still didn't fix,
I could feel it, this injury.
Like this thing, but I know
because and look at these people.
If you could see the people walking by me
and it wasn't a lot of people
but those people were
holding a lot of blocks
on this injury just like they were
when this guy hit my nose really hard.
Like I would be on life support.
They held the injury and
it's all working on magic.
On my deep body magic,
so you know,
anything running on that part
that isn't keeping me alive
and some other people alive,
yeah, it could keep everybody alive.
So yeah, and anybody that's
hooked on that to do bad stuff,
that's just, you know,
they need to get off.
And I hope that they're starting with that
and then working with my charisma,
which they've made into magic.
And when I say magic, they
all get these pieces of magic
and you know, sounds like I'm
crazy but this is really true.
It's all these pieces of me
and then there are so many pieces of me
and they've been taking
copies of my daughter
and pieces of her to where
they said there's nothing left
and they put her in the ocean, her me,
her spirit, her person,
her me and yourself, right?
So when they said that, I
didn't really believe 'em
but I've been thinking about it
and a few times, every time
I try to rescue my mother
who's a prisoner too,
it's just like this long and winding road.
It's very skinny and
private almost down below
and I shut it, and in my day
yesterday, opened it back up.
And that is a trooper.
I had the whole thing
shut, the Finneys, I guess,
it's the Finneys carbon
and I'm not against him
but I know their deep possession.
But I know it sounds so
crazy but I want it on tape.
- [Mark] Okay, it is then.
- Yeah, and one of the things
I hear my mom screaming too
and my dad screaming too.
I hear my dad screaming.
- [Mark] As well?
- Yeah, he's passed away but he, yeah...
Yeah, he wants to get
old in the marine police.
The US marines police.
But -
- [Mark] Okay Caroline, thank you.
- But yeah and then my
sister lives in Seattle
and her daughter, Elizabeth and Drew,
and her husband, Mark, and
his family, the Canslers,
as well as the Keiths,
they all have omni-presences on us
just like they have an
omni-presence for you.
And are you involved in yours?
- [Mark] I'm not.
- You're not, so you're
not, you're just Mark?
- [Mark] Yes.
- Okay.
Well these people, so they're
using pure and holy people
like Mark, myself, and you should see
what they have these people doing
that are part of pieces of us.
And I keep saying to un-do 'em
and I just haven't gotten all the way.
I know there's maybe,
that's why I sit and try to eat,
like I'm eating chicken
broth with stuffing today.
Three different kinds of cereal,
just trying to do whatever I can
and then green bean juice, you know?
And I know they took all this out of it
so hope you get some too.
- [Mark] Caroline -
- Are you bored?
- [Mark] No, no, I'm just
a little confused but -
- Yep.
- [Mark] I'll watch this again,
maybe I'll understand better.
- Yeah, yeah.
- [Mark] All right, well
be careful out there.
- Thank you.
- [Mark] It's a dangerous, crazy world.
- I really appreciate
Mark, he's really cool.
I hope many contributions
can be given to him,
he deserves it, cash, cash money.
- [Mark] First interview I ever did
and I think it's still my favorite.
First one I did.
- Okay, well I'm really happy.
- [Mark] And this one's
interesting as well.
First one was -
- Yeah, that was boring.
- [Mark] First one is
what got me on this track
doing all this.
- Okay, well then I hope I'm
a good inspiration to you.
- [Mark] You are.
- Okay.
- [Mark] Thanks Caroline.
- They're cold.
And this one in the car.
- [Mark] So you've been
murdered three times?
How did they murder you three times?
- Strangulation, muscle
stomach where I went into shock
and passed out.
Oh no, I've been murdered many more times.
Every time I go to sleep I'm murdered
with the miracle.
They use the miracle to put
me down and down and down
and down and down and I die.
- [Mark] And you wake up every morning?
- I always wake up.
I wonder why I wake up.
- [Mark] Hm.
- 'Cause I don't die, or I do die.
I do die.
I don't know.